hello
[Music]
welcome
where the hell have you been
that's all i have to say to you right
now where the hell have you been
hmm
what's going on now
what's the deal
where the hell have you been
[Music]
i'm gonna need you to explain yourself
right now
because there's just no excuses right
now there's no excuses at all you know
you're here now but why not then hmm
what's going on with you
you too busy
[Music]
i'm disappointed in you
so disappointed
[Music]
i can't believe it
where the hell have you been
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
okay hey welcome uh so yeah where the
hell have i been that's what i've been
saying this whole time where the hell
have i been you know what is that all
about anyway let's ignore that question
let's go right into this game that i
love this is frostbunk and i'm just
gonna i'm not even gonna bother
explaining it because you'll get it in
the uh the intro movie if you haven't
heard of it it's a really fun game uh
but i i've gotten really good at the
game so we're going to play it together
and we're going to play it on the
hardest difficulty and i'm going to let
you guys decide
what happens to the people in this
accursed city
you're going to see what's going on in
just a second let me
get that up and ready to go yeah this is
frostbunk you're gonna see what it all
means a lot of people are probably gonna
die because of the choices that you make
but that's on you not on me okay let's
do this watch this
hang on
wait for it
wait for it
wait for it
we roam the still cold world
[Music]
no horizon in sight
[Music]
the rulers of old
stripped
with pride and glory
[Music]
it feels as yesterday we were turning
the wheels of progress
until the frost
stopped it all
suddenly
without a warning
when tides had changed
they changed for all of us
no matter wealth of class
[Music]
we've lost our world to snow
and with it
are last traces
of humanity
[Music]
we bid farewell to plenty
and for those who remained
came the time to adapt
we decided to leave our homes
and head north
we roamed for weeks
maybe months
leaving behind
all the things we once believed had made
us
it was hope
that pushed us forward
slowly
step by step
[Music]
renew the cost of our journey
and we've paid the price
a hundred times
[Music]
finally
the time has come
to build the last city on earth
i'm back now everybody calm yourselves
get your booboo kisses out of the way
everyone line up get your booboo kisses
out of the way because once we get into
this there's going to be no booboo
kisses no there's no there's going to be
no huggy woogies no it's not going to be
fun it's not going to be happy no one's
going to have a good time here i've
already turned my ac down i am freezing
in this room it is so cold my nipples
are so hard but we're going to go into
this so get your boo-boo kisses out of
the way yeah my nose is broken but it's
fine it doesn't even look that bad it's
fine get your booboo kisses out of the
way because once the booboo kisses are
gone it's it's hard mode okay
it's gonna suck or if that if that intro
movie didn't get you hyped up let me
tell you something else about this
imagine okay put yourself in my shoes
not my shoes put yourself in your shoes
you're one of the last humans on earth
and you get to survive in the coldest
place known to man
the arctic region where they've built
the generator that is going to keep us
alive
so long as it keeps running
and the things we have to do to make it
keep running are up to us and those are
on our consciences
and that's in our soul yeah
oh yeah
so i'm gonna let you decide you who
knows nothing about this game i know how
to play this game i've beaten this game
many times i've beaten it on the hardest
difficulty i know how to play this game
i know how to play real good but you
have to make blind choices i'm not going
to try to guide you through it you're
going to make mistakes i'm going to try
to fix them as i go along but all in all
it's in your hands whether we live or
die
okay
good
great good
also yeah i know i haven't been
uploading consistently that should
change now because i've been very busy
but enough of that
it's time
we fled from london oh by the way did
you notice uh did anyone notice the
familiarity of that narrator it's the
same guy that did hunting he who if you
watch unisonness which maybe you do
maybe you don't
uh also just on unison today was a video
of me actually breaking my nose so if
you want to see that actually happening
in real time
uh go over there but we got we we got a
city to build so let's get it also uh if
it wasn't clear i love the music and
just the overall sound design in this
game it is incredible and i love it okay
so
if you played frostpunk before you know
what the deal is but if you haven't then
uh buckle up okay first thing we're
gonna do we're gonna make a law see this
is this is what the game is about you
make laws to try to adapt and survive
uh of the laws that we have in the
beginning we got emergency shift
fighting arena soup food additives if
you don't know what these are emergency
arena
emergency emergency arena we're gonna
put everyone emergency in the arena uh
emergency swift people have to work 24
hours fighting arena they can fight soup
you make soup food additives put sawdust
in the food
that's good for people radical treatment
ah cut their legs off sustain life eh
keep them alive i guess cemetery
not self-explanatory but corpse disposal
put them in a pile that's pretty cool
let's see you can put kids in shelters
or you can make them work
it's all good options so you get to make
the decision so let me make a poll here
real quick we're going to be doing this
through straw poll i know it's not
efficient i know it's not good shut up i
tried to do other pull systems it didn't
work or i'm too stupid okay so hang on
and let's
let's see
well it'll be the f you guys have
complete control over the laws that we
do and i have to
do these
i have to make it work somehow
some of them if you think critically
about it if you actually use your brain
a little bit some of them you know
wouldn't be good to do right away but
maybe would be good later you know you
could think about it that way you know
if you ever thought about that you could
do that
uh some of them really not the best laws
at all
uh
but you know we'll make do
uh child labor or
child shelters
all right let's create this poll you
guys get to vote i'm gonna link this in
the in the in the things
i'm gonna link it i'm gonna link it in
the things in the chat okay here we go
i'm putting the link in the comments the
chat
the comments and the chat
you guys pick whatever you want what are
the results i was trying to get a system
where i could actually put it on stream
but i'm not a professional streamer so i
actually
couldn't get to work
all right what are you what are you
[ __ ] voting for
nothing
got nothing child labor is illegal uh
for now it is
for now it is
for now the answer is for now
did you guys crash this website what is
going on why is it not working
what did you do
what did you do
what did you do you crashed why god
oh my god
you're supposed to kill the people in
the game you're not supposed to kill the
website how did you crash straw poll
how did you do that
how did you crash straw poll
all right
fine i'll do a different one then thanks
thanks gang
really good really good job good you
good job everybody i'm real proud of you
all right
oh my god do i have to type this in
every time i
i think there's a paste option on this
one maybe i could do that
oh my god cemetery corpse disposal
okay child labor child shelters for the
boring people
all right how do i oops oops oh
nice
nice
okay cool create poll let's see how that
does let me get a
notepad everybody just shush it's fine
it's fine do the other one oh actually
no wait you didn't crash it it's working
soup
soup
that's your first soup
soup's your first choice
soup you want to choose soup you want
soup why do you want soup what's wrong
with you why would you pick soup
soup
what are you what are you even thinking
soup
i mean it's not bad eventually but why
why would that be the first pick
why would you pick soup
why should shot stop saying soup all
right fine we're going soup
all right
all right soup it is okay i gotta put
people to work
all right everybody shut up i have i
actually haven't played in like a couple
weeks so i'm a little rusty
just a little bit though
also in this mode there's no pausing so
good good luck with pausing
we got soup great let me go
to the imaginary uh cook house that we
don't have yet and go cook us up some
soup yeah that's good yeah i appreciate
that thank you for the soup yeah
everyone's gonna enjoy a big bowl of
nothing soup because we don't have any
soup
thank you oh for this lovely soup snow
soup it's my favorite soup best soup
ever
everyone loves snow soup
greatest soup actually in my opinion in
my humble opinion best soup
fantastic soup a plus soup you know what
i mean you know what i'm talking about
just
top tier soup
fantastic we have soup
even when i did the test run of this
this this
they didn't pick soup you know
they didn't do this soup because that
just that would just be ridiculous
that'd be absurd why don't anyone pick
soup
why would anyone pick soup i wonder
yeah there would be no point to that
sometimes i delete the
roads here
maybe
maybe i could do that maybe
now i'll go for beacon first
so so there's a lot of things about this
game that that are not going to make
sense oops that are not going to make
sense right away but they'll make sense
later because your tiny little brains
can't handle the big plays that my brain
can make in this game i am so
unbelievably good at this that i'm gonna
be able to counteract your dumb soup
brains you just got your brain your
skull is just a big bowl of soup up
there and that's fine like whatever
everyone needs soup sometimes i guess
but not now is not the time that people
would need that but fine sure all right
let me just let him go you can speed up
time here
for whatever good it's gonna do
there's also to be other moral choices
in this game that it's not just about
making laws people come up and they're
like
boo hoo
my family's been torn apart
[Laughter]
i wish i could find my husband and
daughter
i'm sorry that's very mean anyway she
urges me to hurry i'm
what do you
think i'm doing what do you think i'm
doing anyway these things will pop up
and it'll be people like boo hoo i don't
have any more soup to eat can we please
get some soup and you can either say yes
no or go away and so you guys will be
able to
make those choices too
yeah if we a look if your husband and
daughter didn't make them make it you
know and we still find their frozen
corpses you know
no one discriminates what's in the soup
so you know we'll do it we can we'll do
what we can we'll do it we can we'll do
what we can
we'll do what we can
oh man i'm not gonna be able to
concentrate on whatever i'm doing you
guys are gonna be just a bunch of jerk
wads and make me forget what i'm doing
half the time what am i doing half the
time i don't even know
i have no idea
oh there's a lot of people that play
this game uh probably more meticulously
than i do i don't do that i just plop
things down wherever i feel like it
because i
i'm lazy and i'll also i think a circle
is how this game is supposed to be
played so i just built things in a
circle anyway
everybody shut up
everybody shut up shut up
shut up the polls over there's no poll
right now the next poll's coming up but
the poll for now is not oh what's this
oh
there's no roof over our heads
all right this is your next choice
i'm sorry it's not funny
no
no houses
let's see uh i'll give you a house or
two
i'll give you all the houses
no
house for the baby
all right don't crash draw pull again
okay cool got right gotcha all right
cool
there's we're going to try straw poll
again if you crash it again i'm going to
move on to the other one but
let's see
all right
all the houses all the houses really uh
but hang on hold on there no soup
shelter uh
don't build anything
hold on hey hold hold your horses your
horses need to be held
yes yes yes
[Laughter]
i know i probably swayed the vote with
the boo hoo
but frankly i don't care uh like last
time i tested this out they actually
made me build [ __ ] for my people and i
was like ah what the hell are you guys
even thinking all right this is clear
and cut clear cut oh
boo everyone
oh poor baby oh no shut up sleep in the
snow
you sleep in the snow and you'll like
sleeping in the snow we didn't get
enough coal i forgot about that
uh wisdom of the crowd see this is what
i'm talking about see when facing
demands remember this people usually
look for the quickest solution not the
best one you don't have to agree with
everything they ask for if you fix the
problem your way it's fine thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you very much okay we need to get
uh next time we're gonna need more metal
i'm gonna put some guys to work there uh
let's go ahead and get the cook house so
that we can mix
make our s soup
whatever i also don't bother squeezing
things in i often feel like there's
plenty of room you don't really need to
a lot of people play this game for super
efficiency i just play it for
plopping things down and that being the
end of it i'm also going to build this
just because i also there there's no
logic to it my my city building
structure probably people that play
frostpunk all the time are going to be
so mad at the way that i do this but
like i said
don't know
there is a point like uh we eventually
you know we will need to we'll make soup
but you know if we run out of food which
is very likely in survivor mode we're
not going to do so good
doing good is not what we're going to do
so
give it go out your boohoo kisses and
you all
let's kiss up those tears away
got six hours of
coal left we're fine
it's fine hey look we got another law
coming up oh yeah i forgot people get
sick that's a thing
i forgot about that all right it's law
time baby
it's law time all right let me
i wonder if i can can i
would i please oh yeah this is the stuff
this is what some people
call uh the stuff
okay oh i love paste answers that's good
that's good
that's good that's good stuff
uh what a second law
all right
create
copy
all right
it's on
how do you vote i'm putting a link in
the in the chat you can click on that
and then you go to this play this pla
this mysterious website that lets you
pick what we're gonna do next okay
okay so let's see what the with the
genius
genius geniuses pick
ugh
yes
yes we're putting the kids to work yes
yes
yes
[Music]
yes
kids get out of school and get in the
pile get in that coal pile and you start
digging with those tiny
you start digging away in those gold
piles
that's the thing about this game
it often turns you into an evil
capitalist
all right we're gonna we're gonna put
these
kids to work lazy pieces of crap
get get to get to work kids
get to work you're in the coal pot
we're running out of coal what are you
kids even doing are you even getting
never getting any cold look at all the
kids should be learning not working oh
we have to toil up there now the kids
have to work too
so sad all right let's get let's get on
with it we've been wasting too much time
all right sicko's getting the sicko tent
everybody who's sick just go go hop on
in
hop in the sick tent
i don't i don't even want to see you i
don't want to see anyone sneezing up a
storm on me don't even think about it oh
yeah i guess i should have someone make
soup i guess
whatever
fine
soup we don't need that many people for
soup
well we do need oh no the generator's
shutting down it's gonna be cold
no that's that's a shame that's a shame
that's a shame that's a real shame all
right get to work
excellent
this is good this is good stuff this is
great stuff actually this is actually
incredible stuff this stuff is actually
pretty
pretty nuts
this is pretty incredible stuff going on
here guys
okay uh we're probably gonna i pick this
by the way i pick this you know why i
picked this you know why i picked this
and you don't pick this is because
all the gameplay stuff you leave that up
to me you leave that up to me i will do
the gameplay stuff you all sit back and
do the not gameplay stuff i will take
care of this and i'm gonna do uh the
reason i'm gonna do heaters next is
because
in survivor mode the cold comes very
quickly and if you don't get heaters up
then this cookhouse is not going to work
anymore and then anything on the outside
is also not going to work yada yada
whatever
when can we get to cannibalism
that's what i'm wondering
um
you love this game i love this game too
this game is is phenomenal i i truly do
enjoy the this game it touches on
something that that i often
think is overlooked in terms of uh
in terms of
uh yeah i'm just gonna plop this down
wherever i'm not gonna worry about the
outskirts
get mad um
is it has great feel the game's
feel is incredible the the the mood the
emotions the the
you can feel the suffering of it and it
used to make me sad for the people now
i'm just like you need to work harder
you ungrateful bastards
we're all gonna die if you don't get to
work all right next law aren't you happy
aren't you just so joyous
all right let's take soup and child
labor out of there and now we get
we get extreme child labor which
admittedly would not be the best choice
right now but
leave it up to you
uh
let's see
this is third law
third law in our big book of laws
the best book of laws
there you go
there you go
try that try that
fight
fight fight
why do you want a fighting arena why do
you want a fighting arena
why do you want a fighting arena
why
you animals why do you want a fighting
arena what would be the point
i mean yeah you could fight but
well don't get more child labor now
no both of those are bad options
why would you pick those
why do you want to fight so bad
no it's not the orgy arena it's a
fighting arena well i don't know what
they do in it
did you break this website too
why do you want to fight
i guess we're fighting all right okay
cool we're fighting
this is what we need right now yeah yeah
we definitely don't need like
more labor yeah we don't need people
working harder no we want him to fight
we just need him to get in there
and start punching if they don't start
punching i'm gonna start screaming and
no one's gonna like that all right we're
not gonna get uh enough for the scouting
party tonight which is what i would have
liked
not that i
did the right things to get it i
accidentally got too much steel which
was
stupid for me
but whatever
we're no longer lost and blind
i can't see it i'm lost in blind where
is it what's happening there it is
yeah i didn't look i don't know look
i know i know i don't even have houses
and i got a fighting arena look whatever
it's what the people wanted if they vote
for a fighting arena i'm gonna put down
a fighting arena even if i know that no
one can use it right now there's no
houses
but whatever that's not the point that's
not the point that's not the point of
this it's you guys you're all in control
you're making the decisions i am just
the humble god that is watching over
everything what is this
oh
volunteers have lined up eager to go
looking for our lost people in frostland
the woman who came forward earlier is
among them oh she's old
my husband and daughter
you know what i mean we needed to win i
would not call this a win
but hey there it is guys fighting arena
yep we have that now
oh people are fighting in it i don't
think anybody gets any actual benefits
from it discontent-wise but hey people
are fighting oh that's cool
well that's neat we'll get in there
start fighting
they gonna do it yeah let's let's go
photo mode here
oh no that they don't play
fight em
get em i can't zoom in any more than
this
and they're
[Laughter]
they settled their differences quite
amicably i'm really proud of them they
understood the value of
friendship in the midst of their fight
what a fight everybody what a fight
that was a good fight man that was a
good fight wow really impressed by that
really impressed
all right why are we doing this we got
to speed through this
how soon are people going to start dying
oh god yeah we're starting to get sick
wish we could approach a law that could
maybe fix that that'd be
that'd be oh no one's working anywhere
that's probably a problem
you go there you go there we need a lot
of wood now um let's just work with that
i'm certain that there are sick here
yeah that's fine and probably the last
three are sick anyway i'll just put them
there
okay let's get through this terrible day
another day in the cold it's only
negative 20 degrees celsius
that's not cold
gosh you made me forget about the
overdrive did i not tell you about the
overdrive yeah if the overdrive goes up
too high it provides more heat but uh it
it'll explode
that's a big problem you don't want your
uh thing to sp ah [ __ ]
that's all right well who's gonna die
all right jessamine knew
jessamine oh it's a kid
give me a name everyone give me a name
give me a name
oh this poor kid man
that work place in the coal pile man
we're gonna find a replacement that cool
pile needs more
labor
no i'm not gonna make it explode that's
not a choice you get to make that's not
a choice you get to make you guys will
accidentally kill everybody in time give
it give it time
give it charlie
to charlie charlie
he's got charlie here his biggest
concern is sickness
yeah i'd be worried too
little too nah little timmy yeah there's
a little little timmy
little tinny
little
no
hey hey what did you do
how about little
little timmy tim t
little timmy
little timmy
well we'll know when little timmy dies
all right okay
i would name everyone but there's like
80 citizens so unless we get extremely
bored
oh wait what am i doing oh here's a
here's a tactic
oh
our child got injured at work
are we gonna give the kid a day off or
are we gonna yell
day off
yeah
i'm sorry i hope it was little timmy
that got hurt i mean no i hope it wasn't
little timmy he's going through a lot
right now
all right there you go there's the link
what do you got what do you got scold it
scold it scold it
scold that thing it's called that weird
robot that digs coal
scold it scold it
i like your attitude like it's very good
uh you guys are crashing this website
too you guys need to stop it
i don't appreciate this i don't think
they appreciate it
it's really split
it's really split
oh bless your hearts all those who want
to give the kid a day off but it looks
like yelling at the child
no no guys no sorry man i wish it
weren't such as thus but it was word
yell at it all right listen you little
[ __ ] listen up you little [ __ ]
yeah one second well i'm not i'm not
prepared for this with a shortcut but i
think we can manage this here
all right listen here all right all
right listen here you little [ __ ] yeah
you don't look at me don't look at me in
the eye don't look at me in the eye you
little [ __ ] what were you doing with
that cold huh why are you being so
careless about it oh it's heavy the
pickaxe is heavy i can't go with this
i'm just like shut up
shut up
will you rub some snow
rub some snow in the wound rub some snow
in it rub some snow and you get back to
work you'll get back to work
rub the cold snow it's probably better
for you coal will draw out the
impurities that's what people say you
put a charcoal mask on draws impurities
right out put some coal rub some coal in
it but not too much we need it
all right glad we got that sorted out
i'm gonna have to talk to your parents
about what's that
or your parents are dead
well you got less mouths to feed i guess
all right cool good
see you around kid hope will fall
slightly all right we got that settled
he'll never do it again i was not
researching was i i'm an idiot
uh
we're gonna need wood i think i would
ordinarily have a wall drill by now but
this is an ordinary circumstances you
guys have not given me any labor
besides kids which is fine i'll take it
but
i would i would prefer the wall drill
to be honest
but whatever it's fine
all right are we dead yet a little timmy
dead yet or whatever
guys guys this game's gonna get much
worse than that if you think that me and
mean right now you have no idea what's
coming in this game
oh no
wait little timmy group
little jimmy got big little timmy so
little anymore that's big jimmy
i think
okay this is actually a non-choice they
both are just like open the book of laws
or people could take care of it
themselves i can't sign a new law so
people can take care of it it's fine who
died
i will name all well i shouldn't be
laughing
but whatever it's fine okay it's fine
hey
that's sad
is the body somewhere there
or if it's buried in the snow who
confined
maybe died in the street who knows yeah
you could you could actually find their
dead bodies
anyway all right let's get back into it
we got we got game oh that's what i was
doing that's right i forgot um i need
three sickos what i need is three sickos
here's a pro strat for anybody who wants
to play this game if you got sick people
send them out into the wilds they're
just as good as anybody else
who needs them i should have sent that a
long time ago but whatever we're not
planning to win here apparently
from plan to die that's what we're doing
okay we're gonna where i have some
hunters tonight
i should have changed that over later
but whatever timmy ah look hey dude it
is what it is
oh
ah i probably should have probably
should have done something about that uh
they ain't happy
all right
okay so they're all like oh boo hoo we
don't have houses ahead
bad no house no houses
uh
uh i'll
give houses
i will
give great houses
no houses for you all right um
now be very careful
guys be very careful with this one guys
be very careful
but be very careful with this one be
very careful
be very careful the the straw poll is in
the
in the chat be very careful
be very guys be very careful with this
kill them for speaking out i can't do
that yet
i can't do that yet depending on how we
play our cards that is a possibility but
just be careful with your current
choice here
and you crash the site okay good um
that's great you literally
bro
you broke it you broke it
you broke it
okay it's back
why
why would
why would you kiss them why would you
promise them houses i don't think i can
deliver on that promise
there's a problem there's a problem with
broken promises everybody you voted i'll
give houses at least you didn't do i'll
do better houses uh
and hey we don't have to build one for
timmy timmy doesn't need one he needs a
grave
all right so that that's fair but also
okay
all right
oh
we actually have just enough
wow
look at that
we actually have just enough
fascinating is there anything else that
i need to build right now besides this
besides obviously uh more medical stuff
but whatever
that's another problem
nope we're gonna do this
all right good job everybody
i really used up all my wood i'm now out
of wood which is where you want to be
really honestly
truly
absolutely that's where you want to be
yeah okay at least i'll fulfill that
promise you wanted to give him oh
sorry the game right the game's not
important look the game
everybody shut up you know i'm not a
professional streamer you know i don't
do this for a living you know i'm not
about this you think i'd do this for a
living
if i did that'd be embarrassing for
everyone else that actually tries it
streaming that'd be really sad
it's not be really sad
anyway let's uh we need people working
we got uh the kids need to work harder
they're not working nearly hard enough
um what do we need we just need more
wood i mean we're gonna get the um we're
gonna get the uh sawmill next time which
means that we're going to be able to get
more wood oh
hey
the lost expedition
hey
gosh it's a happy reunion we found
people all right so here's here's a
here's a good question do we uh escort
the people
or do we send them back
um okay all right
uh
survivors
escort them send them back to the city
by the way that send them to the send
them
to city i don't want you to think i'm
sending them out to die
i mean some might die
some may die
i mean some might die
but
it's you know it's all like escort the
survivors to the city
quickly and safely you know quickly and
safely which is
whatever or ah
i didn't mean why are you
no
oh duh oh [ __ ]
ah what were you gonna say what were you
gonna say ah you crashed the site
ah well uh
wait no
hang on ah it's what you wanted anyway
so but hang on
guys no
it's i accidentally clicked escort them
now but that wasn't a good but you
picked it so you're dumb too
it's fine it's what you wanted but also
why did you want it
why would you wanted it why do you want
look at all the time they're going to
waste going all the way back to the city
they're going to take all this time five
and a half hours to go back to the city
then they gotta go back out well they
could the the survivors have legs
they have legs why do you think we built
that big beacon
it's fine it's whatever it's fine it's
whatever
it's fine
it's whatever
all right
why are we not getting enough coal
we should be how those kids are not
working very hard oh
speaking of kids not working very hard
this
protective mother okay all right this
protective mother
refuses to let her daughter go to work
afraid
she'll get injured
okay all right okay all right uh uh
let
her have a day off
get back to
to the cold
all right
i think we all know
i think we all know what's going on here
i think we all know
what the truth is here
okay all right yeah okay can i get can i
get a collective can we can we press
like to give a boohoo can we press like
for a sweet savory boo hoo can we get
one of those one of those like just boo
hoo you know one like equals one
[Laughter]
my god you guys
you guys overwhelmingly boo-hooed that
poor child
and their mother
get back to work get bad boy
back there i don't care if little timmy
your friend died yesterday you get back
to the goal
you won't make an exception you're right
we won't i forgot all right we need a
lot more uh
a lot more uh oh yeah frick oh frick ow
fr oh frick god i'm an idiot oh frick oh
good we have houses but frick ah
ah frick that's bad
i forgot to build gathering posts that's
what i needed the wood for and not the
tents ah i remember now i remember yes
yes yes i remember god damn it damn it
damn it they're gonna freeze
duh whoa hey people
more people to freeze
great
oh yeah cutscene
damn it
i forgot those kids are going to be
really cold in the cold pile
oh look oh reunion ah it's so nice oh
wow
wow
this is great we'll look for others we
sure will we really will we got a crash
site sturdy shelter uh which one has
rations versus which one is i think i'll
go to the crash site first
oh
yeah well law time ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding
[Applause]
what did we get we got fighting arena
why did we get fighting why did we get
fighting arena
why did okay
dueling law
public house
pub
that's people if people don't know what
public house means then you know that is
that is what it that is that is what is
what is fourth law
all right guys make wise choices make
good decisions
good decisions
what i'm not going to say what people
are shouting for but it's not the best
decision
think good decisions you gotta think
good decisions okay
think
really smart decisions okay
we're all here making good choices
that's what we do that's what we love to
do okay we love it we love making good
choices
that's not a good choice
yes who
that's not a good choice that's not the
good choice that's why would we that's
not the good choice why would no guys
we already have soup
i you know
bless you kind souls that were trying to
get me emergency shift just bless your
hearts
you guys picked extreme child labor
we don't have a place for them to do
extra i would love to put them to
extreme labor i would look at that kid
he's happy he's happy working
he's happy but you know
ah
looks like this kid's get
looks like when we built the sawmill i
think some kids are gonna get run
through the sawmill
all right child labor it is ah [ __ ] i
forgot ah there goes my hope
all right we're no hope no hope here why
are we burning how what what do you what
does kids pick up faster
oh yeah that's right because we don't
have extended shifts right of course
oh my god we're gonna die we're gonna
die
bastards
all right this is advanced strategies
here we're gonna pull people off there
to build there we're gonna die
everyone's gonna die
everyone's dying
everyone's gonna die
everyone's gonna die everyone's dying uh
okay it's gonna be cold in the day for
now
i gotta save that cold listen we gotta
make some bold strategies here you're
too cold you need to warm up or else no
one's gonna get heated we gotta make
another gathering post how much is left
in these piles anyway not really that
much ah it's enough oh who's mad
oh someone's grave wheel okay oh that's
not good
all right whatever whatever it's fine
who did it who is it who are you who are
you what hmm frostbite who did it
we must do something
i see okay whatever that's fine that's
perfectly fine
i think kids can build once they go
super saiyan mode that's what i think it
is extreme child labor is kids going
into super saiyan mode pretty sure
pretty sure that's what to translate to
quote that quote that for me tell
everyone i said that
child labor is like kids going super
saiyan they're reaching their full
potential
okay we need
oh we should have faster gathering but
everything's been thrown off here i'm
gonna go for a hunter's gear because
we're gonna start running into a food
problem like
now
foods oh sawmill wait screw that noise
screw your yeah
don't screw it yet
screw it don't screw it screw don't
screw it
what was that the crash site versus what
was it this one's closer grass side i
think grassland's good
screw it don't screw it screw it don't
screw it oh yeah wait let's uh
ev eva
biggest concern bodies in the street
well
it's just little timmy is our body in
the street i don't see it what are you
talking about
what are you talking about
anyway we need a name for this
this is definitely gonna make it person
what's the name give me a name
your name super
super saiyan
so funny that's so funny anyway can i
can we get a name
karen
it's an easy joke but yeah it's an easy
joke it's an easy joke but we'll go over
all right karen here is concerned about
the
bodies in the streets
oh
boo hoo freaking god damn give me one
break i i'm gonna turn on
hang on hold on
hold on
cold homes
oh
heat heat some heat all boo heat okay
hang on it's a lot happening this game
kind of snowballs
the game kind of snowballs a lot of
problems a lot of problems that you
gotta you gotta do deal with you gotta
deal with the doing of the doing doing
dealing with
anyway
uh how are you you good good good to
hear it thanks you thank you thanks you
thanks you thanks you
thanks you thanks to you
okay it's real close on these it's real
close really close really this is really
close
i don't like how close this is i don't
like how close this pole is i don't like
it
um i'm not saying anything i'm not no i
don't like how close that is
i'm closing my ass
refresh
peekaboo
you guys said
heat some heat some heat some okay all
right heat some heat some
oh my god
oh that yeah yeah heat some yeah heat
some heat some yeah heat some
except for uh the fact that i can't heat
some i literally
can't heat some houses i ca i can't he
burn the kids
li if there was an option to turn
corpses into coal i would do it but
there isn't is the thing and also we're
not gonna have enough cold to get
through the night i think some people
are gonna freeze to death in the middle
of the night
like
just why will nobody why will nobody
give me the laws that are gonna actually
help us there's laws that help there's
good healthy laws there's helpful laws
really helpful laws
there are i promise there are some laws
are really good some laws very helpful
the laws that you've signed one has been
helpful
one
one has been very helpful and i'm very
glad that we have that one
i don't even know oh karen no
oh
god
she's dead oh her biggest concern was
bodies in the street and now she has
become one
what a tragedy
what a sadness what a boo-hoo can i get
boo-hoos in the chat please can i get
some boo-hoos i am just really
emotionally broken up about this one
this one is just really eating me up
inside guys i am just boo-hooing up a
storm here god can we get boo-hoos in
the chat please hit the like button to
boohoo
karen here
miss you buddy miss you buddy all right
see you around
see you next time all right and the
generator shutting down people are gonna
freeze to death tonight and they're
starving we're starving everybody
there's a problem there's many problems
guys there's many many problems many
problems are happening here
we're not doing well
we're not oh we don't even have enough
cold egg
cure people
go
we'll pull it back don't worry we'll
pull it back look at this look at this
look at this look at this look at this
food taken care of i told you guys you
needn't worry you needn't worry you need
not worry there is no need to worry if
you worry there is no need
you are worrying
no need no need to worry why worry i'm
not gonna build that just yet because i
have some extras
okay we're gonna put people there we're
gonna definitely put healthy
kids there you're all healthy yeah good
stay healthy
not that i care about your well-being
but i really hard to
it's really difficult to um
make a successful city if you're dead
okay it's fine it's all good man it's
all good guys guys hey no one died in
the middle of the night because the the
the
the the generator thing just i have this
no road we're not gonna get coal from
that that's that's a no coal scenario
that's no coal
that's no coal
is what that is that's no coal
all right kids get to work
go kids go run scamper scamper to the
coal go run frolic frolic in the cold
frolic off to the coal go frolicking
it's good for you when the coal
especially kids go in the cold plate rub
it on your skin and your wounds don't
forget to coal your wounds every
night we're fine this is great
this is good
this is great this is fantastic actually
i would like to point out this is
actually
fantastic
all right we got food baby okay we got
food we're good we're good on food
there's a gloomy cave but i'm gonna go
to the sturdy
we're gonna people are gonna i'll go to
the i'll go to the sturdy shelter i
would like to have another one of those
that'd be nice oh yes let's please get
people 40.
we're fine
we're fine we're fine
all right these boo hoo these kids are
hungry
all right double rations
uh good idea really bad idea
[Music]
okay
should we feed these kids uh
that's that that has bias i'll hang on
let's see feed the kids
kids eat the same no kids eat double
let's make it very clear for people so
there's no confusion here kids eat
double double double guys what's two
times zero let me just i just want to
remind you that what's two times zero
what's two i just want you guys to ask
yourself
what's two times zero
i just want to ask you that just want
you just put that in your head
okay i'm not trying to bias anybody i'm
not being biased about this i'm not not
biasing it i don't want people to think
i'm being biased here
i'm not biased
but
but just just saying
just saying
it's math it's math it's just math it's
just it's math he crashed it again it's
math though you know math you ever do
math you guys do math have you ever
mathed no we can't eat the coal i don't
think
okay all right we're good
we're good we're good kids will eat the
same but it's it's surprisingly close
and i i don't know we can't afford it we
can't afford kids eat the same we can't
afford that the expenses alone would
destroy us all right so we're good here
um let's make some bold moves we're
going to make some money moves we're
making money moves
let's just do it let's just do it let's
let's let's feel it out we're just gonna
go for it
we're going for it we're doing this we
have no food because they that wasn't
running
that's fine
excellent love that we're going straight
to the drawing boards baby
this is good who got sick everyone
everyone got sick is the thing
open for business
unburied corpse well
the thing about it is
um
well
you know
oh there she is
there's karen um
well the thing about that is
[Music]
that's
rebecca brown child listen um
maybe double ration wasn't the worst
more sick beds ah look man
hey this is an easy win actually if you
guys think about this uh
healthcare uh
i will build new posts i will treat the
sick
uh go away
um guys there's a real easy win here
think about it critically if you do what
you want i'm not influencing you i'm not
influencing you i'm not influencing you
at all i'm i'm not influencing you none
okay i'm not influencing you i'm not
giving you the business i'm not trying
to influence you
just think about it
think about it do you thinking about it
are you thinking about your think about
it yeah think about it
yeah think about it
think about it okay yeah think about it
okay you're thinking i bet you're
thinking about it i bet you're thinking
about it i bet you're thinking about it
oh yeah you're thinking about it did you
think about it i bet you thought about
it i bet you thought about it i bet you
really thought about it
[Applause]
okay you didn't think about it that's
the answer you didn't think about it
okay
um you said i promise the sick will be
treated
you didn't think about it okay good all
right great
you notice how i
you notice how i i literally was
already building a new post did anyone
pay attention to that how i was
literally there were posts that were in
the progress of being built
it would have been all right
let's get these
guys in
let's do this that's a good idea let's
go let's go
great great
yeah yeah
okay
you know what it's
fine it's fine
it's fine
oh they're sick
right
all right we're gonna have to pull some
moves
let's make some money moves all right
they're gonna work on that that's now
got a road to it let's put some workers
in there all right listen you you you
you
lovely people have
given me just such a an opportune chance
to really
uh
stretch my legs a bit here you know you
know what i mean i'm really grateful for
that
i really am and i appreciate that and um
i will never forget it i will
i literally will never forget it
unless you
also make me forget it with them the
next nightmare that you're going to
bless me with
um
yeah
fifth law
fifth law give it up for fifth law
fifth law fifth law
fifth
law fifth law everybody give it up for
fifth law
fifth law
fifth fifth law
fifth law we can't do any more child
labor we literally there there's no
other there's no more child labor law it
doesn't keep going
it's not like there's more up here it's
that's it it's all of the jobs there's
no more jobs that they can do would you
want to put them into administration you
want a kid being in my job no
i'm doing a great job
give it up for fifth law fifth law what
do we got how am i gonna be disappointed
now
fifth law oh
gee bless
gee bless
wow the fifth law i finally get
emergency shift this is great
overcrowding's right here but whatever
it's fine i'll take it you know what
i'll take it i'll take it emergency [ __ ]
i can't do any their discontent is too
high
oh someone died
money making moves let's make some money
moves money moves oh there's another
dead
money moves money making moves making
money moves money making moves we're
making money moves okay we're making
money moves all right
we're making money moves okay they're
sick all right
okay oh oh oh yeah i got the healthcare
promise fulfilled i am so good at
keeping people alive so good at it i'm
so good oh there they go they're dead
well last problem for they're too weak
oh there goes some more
well well that's too big that's clear i
usually don't do squishing
not cook house
hunter's hot i wonder if i could fit two
in there i could definitely fit that one
there
yep
i don't know
i'll just
try that let's see you can squish
i could go into detail about this but
you can squish buildings down
that's still big
no i don't care i lit i literally don't
care
i know you could squish it further down
but i just don't care there goes another
one they're really dropping like flies
they are really dying
they are really dying
they are like really dying a lot of them
really dying
so
that's a lot of death
a lot of death wish i could do something
about it but nah
no way
he
no way
uh that ain't gonna happen
that ain't happening
that ain't have
so many sick
it's a lot of sick people
okay we need at least some people in
research
in case you couldn't tell at home this
is not going well
but that's fine
yeah we'll just have one workshop
working
that's great
this is
excellent
i'm super happy about whoa hey
oh look at that
look at that
look at that i need actually what i need
to bring i would go to the steel bridge
right now because i would get that
automaton but
oh maybe it would be a good idea no it's
13 hours i literally need more people
okay i literally need more people
there's people at the
oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no okay it's fine let's let's skate
through this
easy
easy peasy
almost too easy are people still working
no they're no one's working over there
12 and 60. eventually i'm gonna need one
over there
it's all good this is going great except
that's empty but that's fine because you
were gonna go over here anyway weren't
ya weren't you
weren't you
you were don't lie to me
oh there's another one
well okay well that's interesting
all right what do we need now corpses in
the street i
well you know it's really not up to me
huh
it's really not up to me it's you know
these decisions
guys
there's
corpses in the street
okay well it's not so much boohoo
corpses in the street
uh i will solve it
i won't solve it
good
it's really not up to me guys really
really not up to me some people need to
help me here some people need to give me
guidance on what i'm doing just step
over them that's what i was saying
that's what i would say just step over
how did this guy go so skeleton so quick
you know that's what i'm wondering it's
only like day five huh it's only like
day five
burn them i would burn them i would i
would burn them i would i would love to
burn them
look i would i would love that i would
love that i would love to burn the
corpses i would
but it's not an option in this game
for those who are wondering what gamers
is this is frost punk it is probably one
of my favorite games right now it is i
played the crap out of it i played all
the expansions
and okay
interesting you say i will solve this uh
well see the thing is it all comes down
to a law so please don't have bad memory
and then forget what you just promised
okay
um but the the developers of this 11 bit
studios recently said that the the frost
bunk isn't going to get any more updates
and me i'm like i would sell my left nut
for another update to this game
i love this game so much like it's it's
so fun but i crave more content and it's
not moddable and i'm like oh but i'm
please sure may i have some more frost
punk
please
but you know i don't get to control that
all right so the one team of engineer
really pulled through
oh this is so out of order
i think uh
i really wish
that i was able to do my strategy and go
for a wall drill first
but i don't have that option
i'm gonna lose out on the hot homes
yeah well you say that the next law has
to be but the thing is it's right now a
democracy and everyone gets to decide
what the next law is funnily enough
uh so really who knows what it's gonna
be i i could really use more scouts
actually
because more scouts there's tons of like
people and supplies out there especially
in the initial phase that you can get um
i think actually
it would be smart to do more scouts
right now
as mu there's enough coal on the ground
there's enough steel on the ground
i think and there's enough wood with
sawmills that i should be okay
to just go for more scouts it's gonna
get warmer in a couple days so i don't
need heating
if we make it through this which
hopefully we should
i think we should maybe we will oh look
hey the law the law's here hey guys
hey
hey guys hey remember
remember wink what what we promised hey
all right you remember i don't need to i
need to remind you
give it up for six law six law
sis law sis law
this is law what do we just get
what do we get oh emergency shift okay
great
extended shift is next
okay
copy all right it's coming in give it up
for six law
give it up for six law
six law six law you can't put i'm not
gonna i'm gonna shut up you
you can't put
you can't put corpses there i'm just i'm
gonna point that out you can't put
corpses in the you know in the law i'm
not going to say the name of because it
might
influence some people i am an influencer
after all
i can't just say
don't please oh my god
i don't want to see i don't know
what you crashed the site you crashed
the website what is it you crashed it
what is it what is it going to be
you crashed it you crashed it
oh
throw them in a pit
throw them in a pan throw them in a pan
yes
this might set them oh no no
oh i can't
ah
i can't
ah my discontent is too high or my hope
is too low
ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
gosh
[ __ ]
i can't i literally can't
i cannot
because discontent is too high and the
hope is too low i literally can't
[ __ ]
second place of cemetery well
corpse duels it's not a thing you can't
put corpses in the pub you can't make
corpses duel you just can't okay
okay
i know i know it's croc [ __ ] cemetery is
the most useless piece of [ __ ] whatever
it's fine
it's fine
[ __ ]
it's fine and hey next in line they're
they're eager to get in this cemetery
let me tell you they are
rare indigo
ah i'm glad we'll treat the dead with
dignity burn them eat them eat the
corpses why are we just letting all
these corpses go to waste why we could
eat them huh yeah you hear what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying oh yeah
you know what i'm saying all right you
go to this gloomy cave who knows what's
in the gloomy cave i don't know what's
going on
weird weirdo there's a gloomy cave there
oh
work's over everyone get to your goddamn
houses
you gonna build this stupid thing
oh look at that
my promise is broken
the promise that i so intelligently
promised is broken i wonder if they're
mad at me
okay
they're not mad at me yet
not mad at me
okay
they want houses these ungrateful
bastards well i have no oh i do have
wood actually i i might be able to do
this okay
some shelter
all shelter
go away
okay okay okay corpse revival i don't
think that's
i don't think we can raise the dead in
this game i don't think corpse soup i
don't look look you you literally ruined
lo it's ruined it's ruined we can't do
cannibalism anymore because we can't do
corpse piles because the hope was too
low because the discontent was too high
so no you don't get to eat the dead
anymore you don't get to eat the dead
you don't get to you don't get corpse
soup you don't get it because you
you don't get it you don't get it you
can't do it you need a corpse pile to
get corp soup
you need it okay we're just not going to
do it and it wasn't going to be a
problem anyway because i was going to
provide food for everybody everyone's
going to be fine no one is ever going to
get corpse soup and if i see anybody
sneaking some corpses into their soup
and not putting them in the cemetery i'm
gonna have you you've written up i'm
gonna dock your pay
i'm gonna dock your pay
so no one be sneaking any corpses out of
the cemetery or i'm gonna adopt your pay
okay all right what did you say to this
what do you say
some shelter okay that's fair that's
fair that's fair that's literally only
one house but i have wood so i'm just
gonna go ahead and slap down two
that last person the last four are gonna
die anyway so it doesn't matter
oh
[ __ ]
the people are furious
the people are furious at me no hey
listen i'm gonna have people snitching
on people if you're gonna be sneaking
corpses is my
is my camera lagging
is my camera behind
why is it behind is it behind why is it
behind hello hello hello
hello
it's behind why is my camera behind were
some people sneaking corpses and it made
my camera lag were you guys doing that
why were you making my camera oh now
it's good oh now it's good
when i get into the game it kind of is
it lose it
why is it lagging
has it always been doing that bo bo bo
bo has it always been doing that boo boo
but anyway people are mad whatever uh
has it always been doing that
has it been doing that the whole time bo
no that was fine it's just because they
were mad at me
it's because they were mad at me that's
what it was they were just mad at me
whatever well that's dumb
they're dumb
all right whatever
not a big deal
okay shelter promise oh yeah that's the
good stuff
okay oh look at that look at that look
at that
look at that look at that look at that
look at that hey
you know
living here
it's not so bad
this is a pretty nice place
hey
i think we're gonna get along just fine
we're gonna get along real good
just fine
this is great
this is kind of place you can call home
this kind of place you could do corpse
if i see anybody
with a corpse in the middle of the
street i'm gonna be very concerned okay
let's just leave it at that okay
there's no corpses in the street anymore
they're all in the cemetery look we got
dick allard
paulie taylor and molly taylor [ __ ]
but dick we lost dick that's a shame
someone's
what happened to karen did they not bury
karen what about little timmy what did
they not bury him
oh there she is
all right there's karen all right we're
good all right
oh well someone's dead
a susp
spencer as a sponsor a spencer
okay well that's a shame
uh who died
who died
charles chapman oh no charlie chapman
died
oh [ __ ]
oops
oh that's a shame
i know there's still two people homeless
well there's okay no one's homeless
anymore
all right no no one's homeless anymore
we fixed the problem
this [ __ ] is not funny it is not funny
it is not funny
guys okay all right okay this is uh this
is this is one of the scouting
choices this is one of the scouting
choices okay so
we can hear terrified shrieks coming
from a cave uphill when we come closer
several polar bears turn towards us
blocking the entrance there are people
trapped inside and those beasts are
picking them off one by one and feasting
on them
should we leave the bear alone and
they'll kill the survivors or should we
risk
attacking the bears
okay all right fair enough okay
that's a choice
that's the choice
and it is actually a risk so it's it's a
chance beset
by bears
okay
leave the bears
attack the bears
but if we leave the barrels alone
remember they're gonna eat everybody
okay all right we're all clear
we're all clear
polar bear soup polar bear soup
oh
yes yes yes absolutely absolutely yes i
do declare yes i declare yes i'm
i declare big yes maybe it depends on
what we do
all right what did you guys think what
do you guys think what do you guys think
you're cr you crash aside every every
time
one bear soup please for me
one bear oh overwhelming attack the
bears not even a oh okay okay here we
roll today go get em get them
yes
we actually did it hey
all right we got it we're eating bear
soup tonight
we're eating bears
all right
we're eating bears all right we're gonna
eat good tonight
are you guys done with this why are you
only working at 60 oh you're burying the
dead uh well i guess that's a thing you
do with
cemeteries
great good but whatever we got we got
oh we got engineers coming in and that's
great because that's going to help us
heal people why is no one work burying
the dead why would you be doing that
engineers of people who are essential to
heal others so that there aren't more
dead debary
why would you be doing that
why would you be doing that
law time
give it up for seventh law
seventh seventh law
why would they be doing that why would
they be doing that why would they be
doing that all right seventh law
here we go
well we have a cemetery so we we need uh
to add ceremonial
funerals
um actually we just need child shelters
out of here because we can't even do
that how long was that in there
um we got the public house dueling law
extended shift
sorry one second i didn't save over the
last changes i made radical treatment
sustained life okay
give it up for seventh law seventh law
here comes the laying seventh law
we already have extreme child labor it's
not it's not really an option at the
moment
it's not really an option
drop hole coming in
how are you am i going to get
disappointed now
uh results
okay
you
you
god damn bleeding hearts oh
oh
oh we'll sustain life
we'll just sustain it
they'll sustain life sure yeah okay
we'll just sustain life
yeah
sure
they won't be a burden to us
they're not going to be a burden oh we
don't want to have
we don't want to worry about having a
burden in our hospitals of which we only
have a limited amount of space there's
not even enough for everybody oh no it's
fine we're just putting more room
we'll put more in who cares if we can't
actually cure them
we'll just put more in
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] this is
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ]
oh we'll sustain them oh let's just keep
them alive
whatever okay we'll sustain them uh
better than letting them die well they
wouldn't
the funny thing is
they wouldn't die
no i'm not explaining anything guys
because if i explain it i'll reason with
you and you'll be like oh yeah that
makes sense oh markiplier he sure is
smart and handsome man his dick was
uh but then you would be all influenced
by my incredible influencing powers
and then
you would just do whatever i tell you
and that's not how we're doing this
apparently
you guys are just doing
no or the city is not failing the city
is survive it's thriving
we're thriving
this is what thriving looks like
this is what the ghost
well i admire your
candor
we sure probably do have many ghosts
here
and they are very angry but that being
said
i don't think that's an option
i wish it were
i wish it were i wish it were an option
okay we need the observatory okay but
the good news is we just got a bunch of
uh
engineers they're probably mostly sick
but whatever
they will help heal a little quicker we
are out of food
that's really a self-correcting system
if we're out of food then people will
die and then we'll have enough food
almost too easy
no nose is too easy
it's almost too easy
it's this thing that is clearly nearly
too easy
the easiness is too much
too much easiness
right
they confirmed it
man a lot of people are dead
it's fine
it's fine
you will guide me
you will guide me everybody you will
guide me i know you will guide me right
except this whole website is freaking
broken
okay sick people
more post
more treat
go go go
okay what are we doing everybody what
are we good what are we doing what are
we doing
what are we doing we can't make ghost
soup how are you gonna make ghost soup
no one should be making corpse soup
anyway so how are you gonna do it you
better not be making gourse go go or
soup you better not be making gourd soup
huh
don't do it
don't do nothing just don't do nothing
this city would be better off if you
guys didn't do nothing didn't do nothing
is the thing if you guys didn't do
nothing everything would be fine and
we'd be all fine and everyone would be
happy and everyone would be fed if you
guys if you guys just made good choices
if you made good choices you everything
would be fine okay new medical post i
didn't wanna but whatever fine
i'm not gonna tell them to go away
build another one fine
fine it's fine i'll build another one
it's fine
fine
healthcare promise fulfilled
did i build one
did i build another one
what happened
24 hours go
did i build another one i don't remember
building another one
i don't remember that
but there we go now we've got another
one here
two scouting parties i love it i love
that i love it um we're gonna need steel
soon
i know we're gonna need steel okay
where's my sickos at
please tell me these guys are gonna be
sick
all right there they go
perfect
we're gonna get an attempt
at this point i just don't care anymore
just give me whatever you got you know
give me your worst just give me your
worst whatever it is i can overcome it i
can overcome it i am able to overcome
whatever you guys are gonna throw at me
so give me your worst just give me your
worst give me your worst okay
give me your worst okay do whatever you
want just have fun with it at this point
i don't care i don't even care anymore i
don't even care okay you guys do
whatever you want okay
i'll just
uh you guys really want dueling
what do you want dueling was so bad
what do you want to do why do you want
dueling law look at the back yeah
and they can't just have it in the fight
again they got a duel all right you know
what fine we're going we're going child
duels
we're going ghost duels
kids get in the fighting arena let's go
let's go all right let us go
let us go
let us go duels are now legal
sometimes the only way to settle a fight
is to raise the stakes yep thanks hairy
child
you know spectacle to distract us from
the terrible reality yep pretty much
let us go
let us
let us go we're out of coal why are we
at a coal why are you guys not getting
enough coal what's wrong with you kids
get to work harder work harder
what are you guys even doing pathetic
the captains doomed us all yeah shut up
and get the f we trusted the captain and
what do we get
[ __ ] all well that's what happens when
your captain is a conglomeration of over
50 000 people that's just what happens
i didn't make the rules
i didn't do any of this i didn't ask for
this it just is what it is
[Music]
also we're out of coal
which is awesome i'm gonna need to get
uh some kind of other coal source soon
uh but we're just we're so behind on
research where i would ordinarily be we
are incredibly behind on the amount of
research we should have
um
but you know
it is what it is
it just is oh and food i forgot about
getting people in the food but we don't
have enough people
uh
listen i'm just gonna i'm gonna over
rule because it doesn't matter on this
one it's literally the end of the trail
so there's no point in doing
anything but escorting okay so i'm just
i'm overruling you is what i'm saying so
shut up shut up i'm overruling you
this is what it feels like to have power
yes is incredible it's incredible it's
incredible it literally was a non-choice
it was just like whatever if if
basically if you said send them back i
would have just had my scouts meet up
with them halfway and just go over it it
was a non-choice
overrule soup listen guys
there's no soup i don't know how to
break the steel there's just no soup
okay we got steel works um
oof
big oof uh we need some kind of coal
source
i would love
cool thumper we don't have enough people
for coal thumper
i'm thinking probably actually the best
would be coal mining
coal mines are pretty decent
the first level isn't that great
coal thumper is good but it takes so
many people to get going charcoal kiln
actually
if we have the extra wood which we don't
because we don't have the drill but
i guess we can upgrade it oh i hate it
i hate it we could also go for a hot
house but there's no way that i can keep
it warm enough
i'm going for charcoal kill i'm going
for kiln we're going to do the kiln
strat we're going we're going kiln strat
and we're out of coal oh no it's just
out okay let's
just
be fine we're fine
what do you want a child's plea
we found a boy frozen to the bone in the
cemetery next to a fresh grave he must
have been there for hours he wants you
to call an emergency meeting he says
that if you agree his mother will wake
up to attend it
i actually haven't seen that one
i never do this cemetery oh my god
that's so sad
i don't have an emergency meeting button
can i get some boo-hoos in chat
[ __ ]
he must face his loss oh good hopeful
false lately we don't really have much
more of that
okay good this is great guys this is
really good stuff
this is good stuff this is some good
this is good this is what people often
call good stuff
great stuff uh but did i mention that
this game actually isn't all memes it it
can get really sad
this is uh this is a game is made by the
same people that made uh this war of
mine
it may seem like meme town right now
just because of the way i played it but
actually like what do you think about it
is actually it's really messed up it's
really messed up the kind of city that
we've built here with all its child
labor
anyway more corpse soup for me please
boom i'm hungry
what can i build now oh yeah i was gonna
build um
one of these bad boys
one of these bad boys um
i don't have any structure to my city so
why not put it wherever
there's no rules get to work there's no
rules here
yippee
yippee
yippee all right you're also gonna work
24 hours that's gonna kill someone i
know that
oh my god they're hungry
if only we had a corpse pile you know if
only we had a
freaking pile of bodies you know that's
what i would wish we had just a pile of
bodies that's what i want
but no we can't have it actually who
knows what we're gonna have
all right oh we hungy okay
let uh
you shall eat
you shall eat a lot
stop eating so much
all right here we go how am i gonna be
disappointed now
i have a funny feeling
i have a funny feeling i know what you
guys are going to decide i have a funny
feeling i have a funny feeling i've got
a funny feeling you know i got a funny
feeling i got a real funny feeling
i got a funny feeling
a funny feeling
got a funny feeling funny feeling my
feelings are funny my feelings are real
funny i got some funny feelings can i
get a sweet like for funny feelings oh
my god
[Music]
oh
yeah
uh-huh great
yeah uh-huh yeah
uh-huh
yeah we'll oh yeah you shall eat a lot
yep
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah you know what actually
yeah let's do it let's let's make it
happen let's make it happen while the
people we don't have let's definitely
make that happen
oh my god
they're all gravely ill that's wonderful
that is fantastic actually
actually it's funny thing about the the
the hunter's hut so long as one of them
can actually go the others can be like
super ill
so long as one of them can go out there
it's all good
apparently it's all good it's fine
it's no problem no problem for us
all right more people more people
more people
get them in the food chambers get them
in the food chambers all right i'm gonna
send you over here get them in the food
chambers stuff them in stuff them in the
food chambers let's get more engineers
working
and now we're getting it you know now
we're getting it i gotta say now we're
getting it
we weren't getting it before but now who
died overworked
what are we gonna do about this guys end
emergency shifts
we must make sacrifices
what are we going to do
what are we going to do
what are we going to do
he needs more soup we all need more soup
we're trying really hard
oh my god we're trying so hard to get
this soup guys really trying
i really wish we had soup but
man
soup's really elusive our hunters keep
going out trying to get soup but
turns out soup hunting this times a year
is real troublesome it's real
problematic thank you we must make
sacrifices all right we gotta we gotta
make some moves we gotta make some moves
we gotta make some moves all right
uh god i keep forgetting that i have to
give you guys a choice
all right
we came across a functioning automaton
automatons are wondrous
miracles of machinery
this
man oh wait no
send it to city dismantle it
hmm
if we dismantle it we get all of the
resources we get two steam cores and
steel if we send it back to the city it
will go back to the city
automata you cannot make soup out of the
automaton don't think that you can make
soup out of the automaton don't you
cannot dismantle it for soup that is not
a thing that can happen don't let that
influence your decision in this endeavor
it is that's not a thing
you can't it's made of metal you want to
metal soup i don't think that would be
very tasty
although i don't think your your taste
preference on soup okay we're sending it
to the city it's not even a problem it's
sending the city if if if you guys i
swear if you
rabid maniacs when it gets to the city
do not i repeat look me in the eye when
i'm saying this i'm telling you there is
an automaton that is going to be coming
back to the city do not
turn it into soup
okay that's my one order it's not a
request it's an order i'm in charge
apparently
do not
okay
sorry i need to preen do not turn this
automaton into soup okay are you looking
at me in the eye are you looking at me
in the eye i need you to press the like
button to confirm that you are not going
to turn this automaton into soup okay
let it be it is doing its job
and you will let it be
all right good glad we cleared that up
back to the game okay good great this is
great good stuff guys good stuff
deserted bridge hope falls slightly well
you know
don't fall too slightly
don't fall too much
don't fall too much
can i need you
oh
people are desperate
people were talking openly about
overthrowing you bereft of hope they see
no fear diversity and they blame you for
that what should we do
well
well we must hold out
guys we gotta we gotta hold on
can't let things get to us you can't
just
be
sad
we gotta
we gotta go you know we gotta we gotta
do this you know i see he's 30 wood
30 wood
and he's 30 wood
ah
oh i never look at this
shoot
why oh i forgot that one died there
no that's not funny but
yeah i forgot
we're gonna die
we're gonna die
we are all going to die
we're all going to die
death is coming for all of us
we are all going to die
all of us
probably gonna die
my engineers are working the sawmill
we're all gonna die
or
we're all going to survive
that's also an option
that is that is an option i literally
have no clue
how to
i'm overruling you because i literally
same thing i have this other scout here
that's going to go over there there's no
no point there's no point shush
push it's fine
fine it's all good
it's all good baby it's all good
saul goodman
saul goodman saul goodman
it's all good saul
all good man
it's all good man
it's all good
it's all good man
there's no point in doing that without
steam hubs
oh i'm dumb i thought for some reason i
thought i had steam hubs already
whatever it's fine it's all good man
it's all good it's all good whatever
i'll get it next time
it's all good man
it's all good
it's all good
yep
it's all good man
really wish i didn't do that
really ah well hey hey what's going on
guys what's going on
what's what's going on super riots yeah
well
no super riots just yet no super riots
no super riots
okay sleeping outside
uh i'll
give you a tent
i'll give you a
better tent
i won't give you anything
okay i i think this might be the road to
game over because getting hope back up
is really difficult
because you gotta make good on promises
is the thing is the funny thing about it
is the really it's actually really
hilarious about it uh the really
hilarious thing about um
this is that
you know
it's it's just really funny when you
think about it that's the thing uh not
many people think about it that way but
it's really funny
um the funny thing
is
the the funniest thing is uh
okay i give you a ten all right you know
that's fine i was actually to suggest
the same thing i was going to suggest
the exact same thing
i know this isn't good placement i like
i said before i don't care
hopes real low guys
hope is really low but good thing i can
make this ah look at that boom man sure
wish i could fulfill the
starvation promise
that would be cool oh boy ninth law
give it up for ninth law
ninth law indeed
ninth law
great
good
what do we need okay we don't have
dueling anymore we've got that okay but
we do have new ones
we got we got
extra rations for the ill
and then we got
overcrowding stuff them in
okay
okay
all right
okay
poll incoming
poll is incoming everybody poll is
incoming
poll is incoming
okay
soup law we already got the supply that
was your first law if you start talking
about soup again i'm gonna lose my
marbles okay so stop talking about the
soup we're not eating anybody in soup we
don't have overgrounded soup there's no
soup that we can get we got the soup law
we already have soup there's soup you
got soup you want soup we got soup but
we don't have soup because we don't have
any food cause we didn't get enough food
because we weren't able to do the
research that we were supposed to do and
then everyone got sick and then nobody
got what they needed because we weren't
able to work hard enough it's fine
soup law
soup law
let's go oh three cheers for soup law
through soup law
was food additive still in there food
additives was not is no longer an option
i forgot to remove food additives
you can't put anything more in the soup
i don't care how much you want to put
corpses in the soup you cannot put
corpses in the soup it's not possible we
don't have a corpse pile all the corpses
are buried it doesn't matter you don't
want dirt in the soup and you would get
sawdust in the soup but you can't do it
you can't do it so we're gonna we're
gonna next up is overcrowding that's
what it is
next step is overcrowding i'm sorry
that's just what it is
overgrouding that's what it is
and look like magic
like magic all the sick are treated oh
my god what a good law what a good law
what a good law guys what a good law
we are dead i'm doomed i'm dead i'm
doomed i am doomed
i'm doomed i'm doomed i'm doomed i'm
doomed i'm doomed i am doomed
i'm doomed
i'm hope falls yeah hope falls yeah i'm
doomed
i'm doomed i'm doomed i'm doomed soup
we're doomed we're gonna die we're dead
we're dead
yeah
we're dead we're all dead we're dead
dead we're dead we're dead we're dead
dead oh
yay
power up but we didn't need that because
i forgot we didn't have stream hub
yay
yippee
let's turn that research we just did off
oh they're dying they're starving to
death they'd probably be eating corpses
by now but we don't have that either
yippee
yahoo
lee
yay everything's great wonderful why
build them houses everything's good
we're doing good
this is so good
what does it matter dismantle it tear it
all down we're we're making coal soup
guys
we're gonna have coal soup tonight we're
doing it we're dead we're gone yippee
eat em all i say get em all we're dead
oh
there it is don't ah screw it make it
into soup turn it into soup we're gonna
turn that into soup hippie
we're going for a tomato soup it's the
best i love a tomato soup who doesn't i
do we do we love it look automaton well
where is it
uh there it is turn it into soup soup it
up dismantle it we're just more soup in
it
get soups back on the menu
where is it going you go to soup that's
soup now
okay we got soup
that's me by the way that's me walking
away right here that's that's me
because you exiled me
you banished me
a
a band of grim men escorts you under the
generator the waiting crowd is silent
people observe you as you pass their
faces blank as though they were watching
snowfall you are summarily judged and
spared the death sentence and
recognition of your efforts you are
banished from the city instead i did my
best funny thing i didn't is the thing i
really didn't is the thing you know i
didn't i really didn't uh i didn't you
guys you guys you soup mom girls you
soup monsters you soup monsters
literally
gas lit me made me made this is why
democracy doesn't work
you guys don't know what you needed you
guys don't know what you needed you
didn't win you're all dead without me
you are all dead you you you think it
was i was trying you were not trying
what were you doing you'd listen
i'm gonna play something i'ma play
something here i'm gonna play something
i'm gonna play something let's just
imagine what let's let's play out the
last few moments of your lives in the
wonderful city of soup you have built
okay all right let's let's just play
this out okay
this is this is what happens let me a
little spoiler alert for you guys uh a
little spoiler alert uh coming down the
road hot and heavy uh you you okay here
put it in your head you just banished me
right you just banished me okay i'm
walking away you're all like yeah we'll
get soup for days now never ending soup
are you chanting into the night soup
soup soup soup soup soup soup soup soup
soup soup and then
temperature starts to drop
[Music]
oh
what
hang
[Music]
on is it getting colder
oh oh
get the soup into its containers
the cold's coming
oh my god it's getting colder than ever
get the soup back in the container
protect the soap
oh no
it's gonna get colder now good thing we
get rid of our leader though he wasn't
gonna be any good to us anyway
we're on our own
or do we have enough soup
are we ready on our soup
quick
put the kid in the kettle
and then it gets even colder and then
the wind starts blowing really hard
and you find out you were worrying too
much about making soup that you put your
coal in the soup
oh god put more coal in the soup
oh what do we have to call
ah tear down the houses
make soup out of the wood
we're making wood soup
where's the snow coming from
make soup out of snow
[Music]
what do you mean we're out of snow
what are we gonna make soup somehow
tear the generator down
put the generator in the soup
we'll just rip it off
we don't need that heat we need soup put
some spices in it
put some spices in the soup
we're on our spices
how are we gonna stay warm
if we put coal in the soup maybe that'll
be spicy enough
we're out of soup
and then
right at the end of it i'll be walking
away and i'll look back at the city and
i'll just see everyone screaming about
soup automatons are gone all the
buildings have been ripped down
everything's in turmoil everyone's
screaming there's no more soup there's
no more wood
then
you start eating each other
[Music]
oh no
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
you're so good you can eat the neighbors
eat the kids
put the ghosts in the soup
we gotta get the ghosts in the soup
they're just holding out on us where's
all the soup coming from
where did all our soup go did you eat
the soup did we eat the soup
[Music]
and then when you're out of soup
what do you do
you've got nothing left
but each other
[Music]
and then you're all dead
should've listened to me
just saying anyway the only reason i
wanted to play with that song is because
i that's that's the song if you've never
played frostbunk before i would
recommend it it's a great game i'm not
sponsored by it in any way i just really
honestly love the game um
that's the song that plays towards the
end and it's just the most like
holy [ __ ] everything is terrible because
i was playing that on the hardest
difficulty
and i made some mistakes don't get me
wrong mostly just because i was meeman
most of the time but uh this game is is
really fantastic i really love it if you
ever have a chance to play it definitely
do i don't think it's too much on steam
right now it's not like a full price
game uh but just 11 bit studios did a
great job and their soundtrack is
amazing anyway
that's all for today
this experiment went awry but it was fun
i'm glad you were here for it so thank
you everybody so much for being here uh
hope you had a wonderful time uh hope
you learned a few a few things
about what about the uh it's not like
there there's certain people that are
like you have to do a specific order to
this but not necessarily uh thank you
for 27 million subscribers i haven't
said that yet but thank you very much
also videos should resume uh to normal
schedule starting tomorrow uh i've been
off of it for too long uh like doing
unassigned stuff and just other brand
new stuff that's going to be coming up
soon uh it's just been very busy but
also just like i want to get back to
consistent here so it's going to happen
starting tomorrow so thank you
take care of yourselves take care of
each other thank you for joining me for
this fun stream
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye bye bye guys bye have a good one bye
you